dude I went to uh Universal Studios
Horror Nights they have a weekend it's
all week like the weekend senior thing
right oh we can the weekend weekend well
it's the singer the weekend the state
singer yeah weekend what what
w-e-e-k-n-d that's weekend it's weakened
weakened
someone falling I can't feel my face
when I'm with you that's him right yeah
you got something about cocaine right
yeah I don't know you're a vampire I
don't know I don't know I don't know
you're a vampire
I say weakened I don't say weekend
because he spelled it wrong and what he
gets is what he gets oh wow
I was thinking dude how famous do you
have to be where they where they have a
theme a universal yeah you know that
famous here's the problem though he's a
singer right he's not scared I know the
haunted house they're like and I was
like we had like a tour guide yeah uh
and I go the weekend they make things a
singer he goes yeah it's a nightclub and
it's his vision if there's a nightclub
oh just this is a nightclub is it
banging was it banging no wait wait hold
on you brought your kids right
absolutely not they'd be terrified oh
right right right I heard about it
Whiskey and got loose so wait what is it
it's uh it's a haunted house with the
weekend thing about his like music video
everyone was like this is insane I was
like insanely stupid I'm not scared at
all was it supposed to be scary yeah
with hot chicks and they had hot chicks
like from the video oh man it wasn't
scary in any faster some of them were
scary some they they got how much you
think he gets paid for something like
this seven trillion dollars no I mean
it's just that's what I was thinking I I
don't know
I gotta I gotta go
that's why I think how famous you have
to be with me like this I'm with you but
you know it's the weekend
we give a [ __ ] hey you know you don't
coke with me you know the weekend
party's so hard Drake and like Selena
Gomez had to quit chilling with him
because he goes so hard in the paint oh
what the [ __ ] that's the Halloween
costume that's that's not him that's the
haunted house you saw it yeah I went
there with you that the with my girl and
uh two other couple we had the the like
the you know the VIP pass yeah okay dude
if you have to I I don't know if you
have to wait in line that ride was or
that haunted house two hour wait three
hour wait what an adult uh oh it's all
adults all adults with big Daiquiris and
like yeah yeah Mexicans yeah yeah oh
they do that hey hold on was it fun yeah
it was fun all right